des séquelles.
Marie-Isabelle Rochon.
- Tous les jours,
Geneviève Leclerc se rend
dans un CHSLD pour L L L L L L 9
se sont chevauchés dans l'unité
de soin où réside son mari.
Résultat : il a été isolé dans
sa chambre, VIVIVIVIVIVIVIVIVIÈC
- Il a maigri. Il n'a plus...
il n'a plus du tout...
il n'a plus... Il le dira pas
parce de le dire, mais il n'a ps
vraiment le goût de vivre.
C'est clair.
- Sans
sans bénévoles pour aider,
les caphphphphphysiques
et cognitives de nombreuses
pe
ou en résidences privées pour
s s s s s ont drastiquement chu.
Bien des familles rapportent des
pendant 10 jours.
ÈNE DEMCZUK, Comité usagers,
CIUSSS Centre-Ouest-Île-de-Mtl
ne sont pas en phaseavec le nou,
c'est-à-dire celui du variant
de vaccination de nos aînés.
- Et l'isolement pourrait
s'avérer parfois plus mortel
rapporte une étude américaine.
15 000 résidences pour aînés
ont été analysées. Celles avec
ont répertorié moins de décès
liés à la COVID-19. Mais au fil
des mois, ces mêmes résidences
des mortalités non reliées
à la COVID-19.
Dr FADI MASSOUD, g
Hôpital Charles-Le Moyne- - - -,
comme, irrationnel de...
ponctuelles, d'avoir
des mesures d'isolement
ponctuelle
Ce que cette étude vient
nous montrer, c'est que
des mesures à moyen, long terme
néfastes.
- Deux visiteurs par jour
sont désormais autorisés dans
par jour dans les résidences
privées pour aînées. Mais
pour de nombreux patients
ni parler, ces allégements
ne changeront rien, car
le retour des services adaptésus
suspendus.
- C'est une partie de leur santé
qui est aussi importante que p ,
et on leur a enlevé ça.
- Ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.